il aura fallu des mois de l'équipement
lourd
la garde côtière des dizaines de
spécialistes et beaucoup beaucoup de
pression sur les autorités russes
mais aujourd'hui les 86 béluga et 11 et
polar qui ont ému la russie sont bel et
bien libre
en voici quelques-uns qui ont été
relâchés il y à peine une semaine
le dernier de quatre groupes qui sont
particules étaient une vaste opération
sans précédent de sauvetage pour
laquelle n'avions aucune expérience
conclut le directeur de l'institut des
pêches et océans de la russie c'est une
victoire le sentiment d'avoir remporté
la deuxième guerre mondiale dit il
ça fait plus d'un an que les baleines
ont été capturés illégalement par des
braconniers elle était en prison
entassés dans ces petites piscines dans
une baie près de vladivostok
les baleines étaient promises à des
parcs d'amusement en chine jusqu'à ce
que le président poutine interviennent à
la demande de grands experts dont jean
michel cousteau et son collègue charles
trenet qui sont même venus jusqu'en
russie pour planifier la su ce gars est
une opération complexe mais surtout
risqué car c'est à l'aide de grues que
chaque mammifère a été soulevée
lentement avant d'être transportés en
camion puis en bateau vers la presqu'île
de petrov ce qu en mer du japon
le premier groupe des polars serait déjà
1000 kilomètres plus loin au nord selon
les gps que certains portent ou
des pêcheurs en ont même croisé dans la
région cette vidéo le montre refuser un
poids semble et poursuivre sa route
la priorité c'est désormais de
surveiller leur révolution dite charrs
vinik qui particulièrement inquiet des
bélougas qui ont été libéré récemment et
plus près des côtes mais pour le moment
les nouvelles sont bonnes il sort
aujourd'hui la russie est félicité pour
sa persévérance et l'interdire a
dorénavant la capture des baleines même
à des fins éducatives et scientifiques
une zone grise qui ouvrait la porte à
l'abus de ces créatures marines itamar
alter escaut radio canada